people often ask me what is he like as a
director and here is the best example of
that that I can give and apologies to
other people who've heard me talk about
this on other podcasts uh but it's too
good a story and if you've heard it get
ready to hear it again so
um in the uh film one of the first times
we really see the bastards in action is
when Donnie donovitz comes out with the
bats yeah and you know uh Fenway [__]
pack
Teddy [__] ball game uh yeah so uh uh
my buddy He Loves Us yeah he does this
in a lot of movies yeah the thumb over
the shoulder over the shoulder yeah well
he wants to yeah yeah I always thought
he was doing like a Brando thing with
Aldo rain
I never asked him about it specifically
the only thing we ever talked about in
terms of performance we talked about
accents huh because he was he's given he
was doing a little twang he did in
another mood too yeah I'm gonna do this
queen yeah this is the voice I'm gonna
do a little bit who cut my throat it's
never established all right do you want
to know the answer it wasn't cut the
backstory for this car it was a hang it
was a hanging his he he said I'm a
mountain man direct from you know Jim
Bridger so he's from Appalachia
Mississippi somewhere I'm from
aberlaysia and the back story there is
some years earlier in his younger life
he saw a couple of black men being
mistreated basically they were gonna try
to get lynched by some you know racists
in the area and he stepped in oh and
they had saved their lives and in the
process they hung him not enough to kill
him just enough to teach him a lesson oh
wow and that's how he got the scar on
his neck well there you go breaking news
that would be in the book uh probably uh
so anyways
it's us in that ditch uh where you know
we've got the Nazi prisoners and we're
trying to get information out of them
and so that was the first thing we
really shot like the first big thing we
shot and so it's day one of that we were
there for I think six or seven days it's
a big scene there's a lot to shoot a lot
to cover yeah he takes his time because
he can so we're there and I don't know
if you remember my portion of that scene
I'm laughing yeah and uh you know that's
when uh he says uh you know all right
what's my character's name hershberg I'm
gonna send over that uh that sergeant
that crowd Sergeant uh you know I mean
that means you and so he's goes over and
then he gets you know beaten to death
you know that portion of the scene as it
happens uh this scene was a bit larger
than that initially I had quite a bit of
back and
like I said it's happened to me plenty
yeah so I'm it's part of the job I don't
take it personally part of the job part
of the job so we had a little bit of
back and forth there so he says you know
Harrisburg sent over that crowd sergeant
and so as scripted and as shot uh you
know I'm holding my rifle the guy's on
his knees wonderful actor Richard Samuel
is the actor's name who played uh
Sergeant uh uh oh no oh this is it's too
early for me it's a ratchman sergeant
ratchman so um
he's uh I didn't want to point out we
started at 10 A.M I don't know what time
it is and Sam is
40 years old and keeps complaining I we
Katie and I had a good laugh about how
you were like 10 a.m 10 A.M
I got three hours sleep last night it's
true what it's I can't I have to come
back to the bastard story okay clear
asleep last night ask me why do you only
get three hours five you're not gonna
believe the answer this question why
because my wife and I were binging
Downton Abbey
wow and we were like two episodes away
from finishing the sixth season and it
was like two in the morning I was like
damn it fine let's finish it I'm not
going to bed I'll be thinking about it
all night let's do it wow and the last
one is like two hours long
and we did it we stayed up and it was
like
[__] 4 45. this is why you were
drinking a Red Bull when you came here
get up and do Pete Holmes and he's gonna
but you could have pushed it makes your
energy you sure did you brought the good
energy yeah
and you declined the free Magic mind
beverage oh no I'm gonna use that in the
car I'm gonna Freebase
so uh anyway back to bastards uh the
great guy playing the sergeant Sergeant
ratchman Richard saml so he says Al
lorenza uh hershberg send that crowd
Sergeant over and so here's as scripted
I say that means you cupcake and he does
not respond and then I am supposed to
bang him in the back with the butt of my
rifle and then I say when the lieutenant
says move you move
and he still doesn't he still doesn't
react to that and then I am to grab him
by his hair yank him up to his feet and
he turns around at me and looks at me
and we have a little bit of a stare down
and then I you know I said what you know
and when you Lieutenant's talking you
get over there and then he you know
turns around and he walks over and then
you know the rest of the scene he sits
down he has to talk with Aldo donowitz
comes out beats interesting I wonder if
it was another moment because all the
hate that we have or the desire to watch
this guy get hit yeah the baseball bat
which is a lot yeah
I'll admit that when I was watching that
scene it was it was difficult I know
he's a Nazi yeah in a movie still I'm
I'm kind of like ah like seeing somebody
bound and and killed yeah is never fun
no I I I I always get nervous when I
talk this way I'm just saying as a
moviegoer
and also not to yes I get it yeah I
wonder if your part was to help us
remember this guy's a [__] piece of
[__] yeah you know what I mean and the
look he's gonna give you is like disgust
and he's an [__] and he [__] all
that yeah the movie was like five hours
so yeah he shoots everything yeah and
then figures it out in the edit yeah um
so we go to do that portion of the scene
for the first time and he's got the
camera up at the top looking down it's
kind of a medium wide and he's all the
way up there with the camera he doesn't
have a video Village he always stands by
the camera and either watches in a
little viewfinder on the side of the
camera or he watches the actors because
he trusts Bob Richardson his DP to get
the shot right so
we do the first take of that
and he's a cut cut cut and because he's
all the way up there it takes him like
two minutes to run over where the the
ladder is climb all the way down there
come over to talk to his actors and Brad
Pitt's next he going like look at this
that [__] Brad Pitt's like I
think Moneyball will be my next movie
was it yeah it sure was uh at least the
next movie he shot he takes out the book
[Laughter]
Michael Lewis you've done it again so uh
you've got a lot of names he runs he
runs down and he comes over to me and he
pulls me away from all the other actors
all right well here's the thing here's
the thing okay
um
you're some [__] American Jewish kid
this guy is a [__] Sergeant in the
Nazi army okay he would kill you with
his bare [__] hands if he could and
the only thing stopping him from doing
that is the fact that you're holding the
rifle he's not and there are 12 other
rifles around him
he knows one wrong move and he's going
to get blasted to hell that's the only
thing stopping him from [__] killing
you and you know that you want him to
make a move you want an excuse
to tell your [__] Lieutenant what
could I do Lieutenant he was anti he
came at me I put a hole through his
chest you're looking for the excuse man
I need to feel the fire I need to feel
the want from you that you want this guy
to make a move so you can put a hole in
his neck and I was like done
and then he goes over to Richard and
pulls him aside
and I do not know what they're saying
and then the last thing he says right
before he goes back is he goes okay
nobody talked to each other stay in the
moment and then he runs back up to the
stair runs over the thing okay
and we go to do this scene a second time
and now uh hershberg send that crowd
Sergeant over and uh that means you
cupcake and now I'm [__] in it now
it's fire and I bang him so hard I know
I kind of hurt him when I bang him with
the butt of the rifles Sergeant shade
lights in and says you move you move and
I yank him up to his feet and he turns
around he's staring at me and I got my
rifle and it's a moment and it's going
on way longer than it did last time and
I'm looking at him he's looking at me
when I start poking them in the chest
with the butt or with the with the front
of the other rifle he's looking at me
and it's a moment and it goes on so long
finally stops
fixes his jacket turns and walks away
and then they get another little piece
and then the scene ends oh God
not again do that again we're gonna go
again and then he comes over and I say
Richard what did he tell you
and he said oh
um he told me that when I turn around
and you point the gun at me that if I
didn't believe that you'd really shoot
me that I should try to grab the gun
away from you
and then that would be the new scene and
he'd rewrite it
[Laughter]
and then that would be the new scene and
I'd rewrite it in the woods in the woods
in the middle of nowhere in Germany we
need 10 minutes
yep
because he needed something authentic
wow and if we couldn't get to the
authentic thing he wanted to find the
authentic thing we could do and he'd
make that the scene and what he wanted
and what do you want well we'll edit
that story out I I think you should I
didn't like it I think you should edit
that I don't like you oh well the
feeling is mutual
you're too tall
[Music]